tournoi fantastique moi je vais ouvrir
les tchats d'ouvrir tout de partouzes
ouvrir dix corps j'ai tout d'ouvrir
ça va être complètement dingue les amis
ça va être le tournoi le tournoi mensuel
septembre le tournoi de la rentrée
le tournoi qui fait mal non je vois que
le stream est parti sous là je me prends
une pub sur mon propre stream
ça commence bien alors on va mettre le
mode voilà on va choper le chat voilà
comme ça le chat et là on voit bien
l'écran alors est-ce qu'il ya du monde
qui est déjà arrivé
où en sommes nous où en sommes-nous pour
le tournoi mensuel alors le tournoi
c'est là et je vais mettre un petit lien
sur mon facebook
avec voilà les choper le facebook ici et
on va choper le lien du tournoi on va
choper le lien du club
je pense qu'on est bon
salut foucault f7
ce soir à 20h35
pour y participer allez dans l'adresse
je vais écrire un petit peu chez ce
point comme tirer live ou connectez vous
au direct pour obtenir de l'aide et
comme ça on va leur mettre le lien vers
le direct ils sont très très content
boum
comme ça ça c'est bon ça c'est publié
ok donc là on est bon et on va mettre ça
comme ça
ce soir à 20h35 mettre le lien du club
et on va mettre ça comme ça
et comme ça on va être bon hop
donc ça c'est parfait alors maintenant
on va voir combien de personnes dans le
tournoi alors on est combien pour le
monde et 0 pour moi y'a personne qui ne
s'est inscrit pendant le tournoi
donc on est un peu en pls
alors
[Musique]
alors le chat est complètement débile
sur twitch le chat est complètement
débile surtout ils ont pourra pas
répondre pour le moment et on va aller
voir on va aller voir sur sur le jazz
comme tv on va aller voir sur une chaise
comme tv et on va être bon on va être
dans les temps dont les gens lisent plus
de défier non ça la réponse est simple
et clair quand il faut faire pour
regarder les vidéos
difficile de répondre que si la personne
n'arrive pas regarder la vidéo on est
mal à faire frémir salue ici aussi qui
est de partout
l'homme s'est fait éliminer aujourd'hui
ouais mais c'est pas la plus grosse
surprise à sa propre surprise ça c'est
quand même un hand écart yakine sais
quelle forme habitués du 5 plus des
rôles tournant ce soir
allez allez on s'inscrit
on sent ce faire je prends des machins
ça alors j'ai un copain qui voulait le
jouer je vais l'envoyer par ici
comme ça
on va expliquer à tout le monde en même
temps
alors je vais vous mettre le lien du
club dans un premier temps faut vous
inscrire vous inscriviez pardon au club
lead stream et après que vous alliez
pour jouer un tournoi donc le club
l'ithry neuvième est l'adresse sur les
deux chat donc on va la voir sur le chat
numéro 1 et sur le skate numéro 2 donc
ok on est bon on va voir le chat numéro
un et le chat numéro 2 donc faut juste
s'inscrire au club et après aller aller
dans le dans la section live et
normalement ça doit aller dans la
section tournois pardon et normalement
ça doit aller
alors je n'ai pas le machin sur le bon
truc on va revenir de mettre le chat là
on va remettre l'adresse du club ici hop
comme ça l'adresse du club est partout
armande à quatre joueurs et on va aller
le dire aussi sur discorde comme ça on
sera deux partout on sera prêts pour
notre tournoi mensuel donc c'est tous
les premiers jeudis du mois qu'a
fortiori un premier jeudi du mois
là on est bon
on écrit par tout ça tout le monde est
au courant et ça va être
on va passer une bonne heure pendant le
tournoi l'ensemble ça va être ça est
très tranquille or qu'est-ce qu'on ait
ce coin du lourd qui est inscrit déjà je
me demande je veux voir qui est inscrit
on a deux gros chat maintenant je ne
sais pas ce qui se passe nous avons deux
gros chat est ce que c'est un troll le
deuxième puisque ces gros shaq à de
pseudo
mais je pense que groucha s'est fait
trop les a vraiment c'est un joueur
alors je vais je vais essayer d'ajouter
un petit moment je suis un peu baissé la
caméra et je vais essayer d'ajouter
je vais essayer d'ajouter le truc du
tour noir caché ça l'a vraiment cinq
joueurs
je vais te racheter une petite capture
d'écran pour que vous voyez
ça vous serais très très heureux
voilà donc en haut à droite on voit pas
très bien mais en fait on va droite
voilà c'est comme ça votre endroit pour
pour éventuellement jouer des parties
faut que vous alliez la dent tournoi des
petites médailles
ceux qui sont pas français tournoi up
coming donc ça c'est pas s'est pas
traduit donc à venir vous cliquez sur
tournois mensuels est normalement vous
allez tomber là dessus sur ce petit
écran après moi c'était déjà ouvert et
vous avez vous avez du tournoi donc la
pensée de joueurs avec avec un maître
international ce soir à rio il est là
nombreux diamant il va vous faire très
très mal
non maître international ce soir tu vas
essayer de prendre de prendre le premier
prix des joueurs un peu plus faibles
derrière mais on a déjà vu des tournées
et des surprises dans ce tournoi
attention attention il peut y avoir des
surprises
un lycée pas forcément facile de
comprendre comment s'inscrire et on a un
membre russe qui nous dit qu'ils nous
demande de l'aider alors on va c'est à
dire un petit mot en russe a c'est de
dire un petit mot en russe pour qu'ils
puissent pour qu'il puisse trouver si
nous écoutent encore ou pas on va voir
s'il écrit encore quelque chose
pour accéder à un feu d'abord aller dans
le club et ensuite dans un deuxième
temps dans un premier temps le club lice
rimons inscrits dans le club et après on
va s'inscrire dans le tournoi
10 quel moyenne lots joueurs présents
dans le tournoi binbin pas mal pour le
monde et que cette c'est pas normal déjà
été 20 25 mais bon c'est la rentrée veut
m'entendre parler rice allez va le faire
en russie ratifier ou de chasse tu vas
tu y retournes irait nunaa clic nous
tenace il court en aac l'oubli de stream
appâtant mutine appelée zone i n'aura ni
de stams fournirait un coming in iz live
jack la piste n'a pas rousski il pas
temps dans votre signe v clic luciana
tournoi mensuel
mais si je n'ai tournure inattendue
participent innovative participer ou de
chasse tovati scarifié beau matthews les
roues ce qui posera tous les bruits n'a
pas niable donc en fait grand chose à
faire dans lequel il suffit juste de
cliquer sur le lien du club
pacy baynham aux sais pas s'il va tibia
et donc ouais donc sur le lien du club
il faudrait il faut s'inscrire je crois
qu'il ya écrit rejoindre le club
quelque part sur la page tout simplement
le rejoindre et c'est parti on va déjà
11 est ensuite allé dans la plaie eason
13 points comme tirer live slash live
pâtir et slash plus tôt
je vais te mettre le lien
comme s'ils jouaient en direct sur check
point comme en fait the bras qui nous
dit 33 je vois pas ton temps à peut-être
parce que tu n'es pas membres du club
bitstream
c'est une possibilité sur est pas bon tu
peux tu ne peux pas voir le tournoi de
nouveaux disques indien qui est venu
puis reparti
il ya un jour qui est venu qui est
reparti
est-ce que inna modja fa réussi à
s'inscrire on va bientôt le savoir
je ne vois pas de joueurs russes donc je
ne pense pas mais peut-être qu'il va
réussir à nous rejoindre
alors s'il a réussi à nous rejoindre
malade y est il est là
il est là
ce terme explique nous écrit sur un chat
ne pourra pas ce que demain ils allient
c'est bien tenté mais nous ne croyons
pas nous demanda piscine quand comment
ce tournoi bitstream à 20h35 dans 22
minutes
dans 22 petites minutes
si tu te rends compte à cause de toi
j'ai préparé la grotte pendant un quart
d'heure ouais mais ça va être utile ça
va être très utile pour préparer la
grotte dans ce tournoi et d'avoir
préparé la ruine tu pourrais te faire
humidifiés ça peut être très dangereux
peut-être mettre le lien vers vernotte
discorde aussi si les gens si les gens
veulent venir discuter avec noire en
dehors des stream avec la communauté
bisbilles stream je vous mets le lien du
discorde les deux côtés sur sur twitch
et surat et sur pièce et sur chaise
comme alors
alors alors alors on en est à quoi on en
est à 16 joueurs assez bossé joueurs
c'est beau allez on va essayer je crois
que notre corps c'est quelque chose
comme 28 ou 30 allées on essaye de se
motiver on appelle les poteaux on
appelle les copains ton est fantastique
maître international c'est le premier
mettra pas à celle qui joue un homme de
tournoi des grands maîtres que je crois
qu'on n'a jamais eu de on a eu des
maîtres fit des grands maîtres premier
maître international à jouer comment on
fait pour rejoindre l'équipe alors sur
sur la page du club ni stream il doit y
avoir quelque part terre à 80 pour pour
rejoindre rejoindre le club ou quelque
chose comme ça comme j'ai déjà rejoint
je ne sais pas comment on fait
exactement mais ccc sur la page du club
peut-être que tu l'as déjà rejoint
d'ailleurs je ne vois plus puisque je
suis déjà membre du club l'a
automatiquement
je souffre pour pour le rejoindre de
nouveau qu'est-ce qu'on nous écrit sur
facebook sur facebook on à fond on est
deux on est sur les médias sociaux on
est deux partout
début dans 19 minutes exactement emery
player merci à rioz qui nous fait le le
sav tu clique sur le lien de kevin et ya
participé ouais voilà participer valls
est pas sans sexe était rejoint le club
c'est participer
ça va être je pense sur un bouton un
bouton orange ou un bouton rouge alors
15 joueuses ont perdu un joueur pendant
que les écarts n'est que quand vont
s'approcher du record
allez on se bat on se bat
on se bat à fond les poteaux on y va
mais ça commence en 18 minutes
ayem replayer qui a très envie d'avoir
un compte à rebours est aléatoire il ya
du niveau et du skill ce mois ci sa est
sympa a commenté
il ya du ce qu'il y à du skill il ya du
gros ce qu'il
matador qui chambre sur le chat 103 104
euros de cashprize c'est bien ça qu'il
fallait voir assuré sinon l'ennemi va va
se barrer du tournoi voilà je pense qu
un si beau trophée gagné le tournoi
mensuel bitstream fin c'est
l'accomplissement d'une carrière famille
elle a déjà gagné je l' ai déjà gagné
voilà c c'est sûr qu'il soit que ce
tournoi est gagnée à l'iap ya plus
beaucoup d'objectifs on voit on voit que
beaucoup n'ont pas réussi à le gagner on
pense à k-rma l on pense à mvl qui sont
partis à tbilissi joueurs tournois de
seconde zone pour éviter justement
d'affronter le tournoi mensuel bitstream
qui est quand même un peu le la marche
au dessus si vous voulez quoi c'est fou
ça quand même complètement une ascension
c'est un peu l'everest des tournois
d'échecs
la lega toile et j'ai déjà gagné voilà
déjà voilà c'est un peu comme ça qu'on
se présente sur le cv du hallegatte ans
avec kiel vainqueur du tour mensuel miss
stream avec le mois et tout ça six
matches qui vont soir kevin c'est le
calme avant la tempête à la tempête a
déjà commencé à nous sommes 18
ça vient petit à petit alors on a un
joueur tient on a un joueur un joueur
mexicain a fortiori peut-être le premier
mexicain à venir se frotter à nous est
de 0,17 ou on gagne demain mon père élan
ils viennent dans l'oreille non tournant
est trop dur pour moi je ne reste pas
dans ce tournoi ils partent et
reviennent
alors alors est-ce que ça continue à
venir
est-ce que ça commandes du navire
indique karine a perdu exclu aujourd'hui
pour rejoindre le tour d'istrie oui il
ya des rumeurs effectivement valderrama
il ya des rumeurs qui en compte
concernant la défaite de karuïa keane
nature est tout à fait tout à fait tout
à fait et ce qu'il réussira quand même
avoir le courage de venir après cc c'est
autre chose c'est c'est une autre c'est
notre question illana fossiles et les
gardes des lianes a fêté évidemment lié
à ce tournoi blitzkrieg
donc on est 17 c'est déjà pas mal mais
on peut être plus on peut être plus
c'est tonton
peut être vain on peut être vain on peut
être devant après y'a des gens qui
arrivent je pense aux derniers ans parce
qu'ils sont courants ils connaissent le
tournoi il arrive au dernier moment
a fortiori savent ils savent ce qu'est
ce qu'ils font ils sont au courant mais
ils rejoignent au dernier moment
ouais nv länder man au prochain tour
c'est un bon troisième tour un
finalement pour maxime
on avait peur des lianes of y avait
aussi owen qui pouvaient très dangereux
linderman c'est quand même un peu moins
fort mais bon il faudra se méfier
c'est rémy fois il faut aller dans
l'accueil jouer et participer au tournoi
vraie femme en fait c'est pas si
compliqué ainsi il faut l'avoir fait une
fois mais son ca assez simple c'est
juste pas super intuitif on va dire ça
comme ça parce qu'on peut pas participer
au tournoi via la page club il faut
repasser dans la page live
allez allez allez donc çà çà çà bon bah
je pense qu'on est pas mal moi je pense
qu on a à peu près tout fait on a à peu
près bon c'est amusant mascaraque in
disguise ray il s'est caché
ne venez pas qu'on le sache bien vu
allez y à tort bienvenus
jetez un coup d'oeil on a reçu plein de
mails on va voir est ce que c'est un
rapport à ce que les mails ont un
rapport avec le tournoi tmn un rapport
avec le tournoi ou pas du tout j'ai
l'impression que ça aucun rapport non
sans rapport avec mes dernières vidéos
la vidéo sur maxime arrêté lien qui fait
un message la kleienn très content des
vidéos
alors alors alors on sommes nous nous
sommes 18 nous sommes 18 c'est pas mal
je suis un peu 10 des étapes ce chat dix
corps noir sont que personne ne parle
jamais en fait parce que thomas muc
c'est parti thomas mutz parlait tout le
temps dans le chatt discorde de ville
thomas mix n'est plus là les gens ne
parlent plus de gens ne parlent plus
dans le camp de chati hors amm est
uniquement participé alors il faut que
tu trouves le club lead stream que tu
cliques sur participer alors je te
maignien ahmed ahmed donc filles sur
participer et après tu vas sur sur la
plate-forme de jeux en direct de check
point comme tu vas dans tournoi comme je
suis en train de le faire et tu vas voir
le toit mensuel il faut cliquer
participer donc c'est une double
participation tu dois faire
ouais du score sans un chat discorde ccd
chat deux communautés
j'ai mis un lien un peu plus haut
un sixième coupe discorde s'est même pas
là on va lui remettre le lien vers le
groupe discorde
on met des liens de partout ce soir on
est on est chaud patate
moi je ne fais pas le tournoi je
commence le tournoi c'est déjà pas mal
c'est déjà pas mal
c'est quand on est tous les deux avec
fabien c soit famien soit moi qui le
joue plutôt famien d'ailleurs
généralement mais moi je ne fais que le
commenter il fait très plaisir aux gens
vous savez pas mais ça ça permet de voir
les parties commenté après ils sont
souvent très content
mais rien qui arrive sur une chaise
discorde
on est 21 amène nous a rejoint spooky
boogie nous a rejoint
on va dans neuf minutes
ado l'alligator qui est de castres
casque qui s'apprête à recevoir
montpellier ce week end comme 14 grosse
réception
80 spectateurs
21 joueurs matin c'est déjà pas mal
c'est un beau tournoi 7 assez fort en
eau peuvent peut être peut y avoir des
surprises
on va voir on va voir
on va voir ce que ça donne alors
mapa magnin plusieurs personnes qui sont
arrivées là bas aussi
alors on et 21 est ce qu'il ya des
personnes qui parlent et plus personne
qui parle d'une personne qui parle moi
aussi je vais me calmer un petit peu
avant de commencer à parler en france à
part les 22 joueurs
encore un nouveau participant on est pas
mal on est pas mal
target en attendant non non non pas de
bulle at il fait beaucoup trop d'échecs
là les derniers jours il faut que je me
calme un peu beaucoup de vidéos avec la
coupe du monde
les live de la coupe du monde les
machins plutôt rendu jeudi là je suis en
forme mais bon si en plus je rajoute des
bullet après ça me fait une une overdose
d'échec
donc on va éviter on va éviter la se
concentrer sur sur l'objectif
d'aujourd'hui le tournoi dont tout le
monde parle
alors alors alors plus que 7 minutes
plus que 7 minutes
toujours entre deux joueurs
donc c'est un tournoi international
vu qu'on a plusieurs joueurs plusieurs
nationalités participent au tournoi
exactement ce tournoi accueille de hand
c'est tous les premiers jeudis du mois
nous reste et il ne reste plus que cinq
minutes
alors alors alors alors mon message
l'aïe se passe pas grand chose
je pense que mario est clairement favori
du tournoi quand même et 200 points de
plus que le deuxième mais bon il ya
quand même trois joueurs derrière qui
suivent live sur à 200 300 points elo
deux mois qu'ils peuvent qui peuvent lui
poser problème je pense que pour pascal
gos sera déjà difficile quand même de
jouer la gagne
quoique mais il ya à mon avis un favori
clair qu'ils se détacher 3 outsider pour
ce tournoi qui sont là et puis après ça
tout peut arriver mais ça devient quand
même moins moins fort alors plus que
cinq minutes nationale et vous vous
inscrire il faut se dépêcher il faut se
dépêcher
là il reste très peu de temps pour
s'inscrire plus que 4 minutes et on est
il ya des joueurs qui des habitués qui
arrive juste à temps ils savent que
c'est 20h35 il arrive pile à l'heure
mais demain il y aura le tournoi
discorde lui qui commence à 20h05
et c'est tous les vendredis mais parfois
on n'arrive pas à le jouer ce qui a pas
assez de joueurs présents
dans 24 participants
que trois minutes
voir les mêmes devant il n'y a pas de
pas de joueurs qui viennent se greffer
de tahiti qui n'arrivent pas à
s'inscrire il faut très très très
rapidement tu participes au club lice
rim vais te mettre le lien est taillé
sur la page live mais attention tu n'as
plus que deux minutes ça va être ça va
être la course pour toi c'est déjà un
tournoi dans le tournoi pour t'inscrire
c'est déjà un tournant dans le tournoi
pour pour pour arriver à y participer
sur 24 d'après foot and en tournant et
que tu trouves le tournoi mensuel on se
défend pas mal quand même on a pas mal
de monde dans notre tournoi
comparé aux autres tournois où tout le
monde peut participer pièces pour encore
on a notre notre petit tournoi qui
marche pas mal maintenant quand même
25e joueur qui est venue se greffer
alors est-ce que c'est dans le haut du
tableau ou pas non on garde toujours les
mêmes joueurs en haut de tableau
c'est quelqu'un qui sait lui qui est
venu se greffer en milieu de tableau il
reste plus que deux minutes paul ont pas
réussir à arriver au 30
sur 25 26
est ce que ça a changé l'eau du tableau
non le du tableau est toujours pareil
tant pis 2002 qui arrivait quand même
mais 10 au beach sa cdc de l'habitude et
chez ceux plus gros chat c'est un autre
gros chat terra qui est finalement la
mata faire hhbc des joies des habitués
il ne reste plus qu'une minute une
minute trente même pas j'écris plus que
plus qu'une minute 26 joueurs
27 j'avais envie de dire 27 gâteurs
taille taille qui a réussi à s'inscrire
pour avoir un toit c'est déjà une bonne
chose il te restait très peu de temps
pour y arriver c'est tous les premiers
jeudi l'arrêt france ici je suis nul
mais je voulais jouer bach est inquiète
par on est on est tous assez mauvais
donc nos complexes pas attention
attention attention on d'une minute 29
alors peut-être réussir être 30
parce que c'est venu d'un an dans le du
tournoi c'est toujours les mêmes
ils sont venus pour gagner ils sont
venus pour le gagner le tournoi
ce qu'on va réussir à faire 30 un nombre
pair
square bloqué à 29 plus qu'une trentaine
de secondes
plus qu'une trentaine de secondes
je pense ça va ça va resté à 20 900
ribéry
ça part un peu genre troicki les paris
sont ouverts sera le vainqueur va quand
même favori favori are you et c'est
parti pic 30 joueurs il ya un 30e qui
est venu sur le gong et on va suivre
tu devrais suivre quelqu'un qu'on a vu
tu aurais je suivrai tight ait un qui
arrive au dernier moment
tahiti on va suivre cette partie qu'est
ce qui nous a fait le tahiti nous a fait
4 des 5 il a fait une scandinaves qui
est roi dame à 5 et hhbc des qui a
laissé jouer une petite variante avec
des 3 g iii pour pas forcément rentrer
dans les grandes variantes on va enlever
ça et qu on mettra le classement du
tournoi au cas où jouent cette petite
variante qui est pas mauvaise pour les
blancs pour éviter la théorie s'offre
pas forcément un grand a un gros
avantage mais ça permet de d'avoir une
position où ça joue fort qui développe
peut-être le fouet et peut-être
éventuellement des clous et j'allais
dire parce que là il commence à avoir un
problème pour hachage bcdc ce cavalier
f3 il aurait dû plutôt commencer par h3
pour pour éviter pour éviter cette dame
d'arrivée en 1 h 5
parce que maintenant que la dame est
arrivée en h5
c'est très pénible c'est pour ça qu'il a
fallu 3 maintenant parce qu'il y avait
cette menace de cavalier e 5 pour venir
gagner le cavalier c'était déjà pas si
simple que ça de de protéger un c'est
très mauvais quand vous faites cloud est
comme ça donc il a dit c'est de l'art y
est le pion h3 mais le problème c'est
que maintenant son roi est très faible
il a plus eu dans le fou dans le fion
ghetto et ya le cavalier qui va
rapidement arrivants g4 avec par exemple
comme nas kg 4 carats lieu 5 pour déjà
venir essayer d'enfoncer faire du damage
de maths en déviant le cavalier qui en
f3 king5 ils essayent de chasser la dame
alors est-ce qu'on va proposer les
changes des dames côté noir avec du
chômage 5 ou dame g4 ou plutôt garder
les dames sur l'échiquier comme on a du
potentiel offensif encore les deux sont
jouables avantage 2
gardez les dames c'est probablement le
roi blanc est plus faible mais comme on
a déjà un avantage matériel on peut se
dire que c'est mieux d'échanger les
dames et de jouer une petite finale avec
un pion plus qui doit être quand même
assez tranquille normalement c'est pas
toujours facile comme choix à faire il
décide de garder les dames
peut-être qu hsbc n'a intérêt à jouer
dame f3 qui son adversaire veut pas
échangé des dames pour le suivre et et
quelque part puisque logiquement se
disant qui va peut-être il va peut-être
à repartir avec sa dame tout bêtement et
donc gagner du temps où il fait qu'elle
est de 4 pas trop de menaces mais
difficile à jouer pour les bleus en fait
il a peut être perdu sa pièce maîtresse
et son roi c'est bien affaibli à j-6
bien joué maintenant si lecavalier part
on perd le pion aux 4 et sur cavaliers
pros f6 les noms peuvent même faire j'ai
pris mes fils à la rigueur mais je
prendrais juste du cavalier et on
repousse le cavalier et les noirs vont
continuer à se développer pourront faire
grand cas prêts en voyage 5 h 4 ça
paraît très très dangereux tout ça ça me
paraît très dangereux j'étais jeune
café dame f3 maintenant et puis on prend
un g5 c'est juste un cadeau un bâchage
les cds qui vient juste d'offrir une
pièce est à mon avis qui peut déjà
abandonné donc on va on va on va changer
de parti un lacet c'est un peu la cata
on va suivre
on va suivre deux alligators allez on
l'a vu il a déjà gagné le tournoi et il
a les noirs contre tigre heure aucune
position une française variante d'avant
ce qui a tourné de manière un peu
étrange donc les blancs qui n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas protégé comme on le
fait habituellement le pion le pion des
quatre avec le pion c3 pour m'inscrire
la chaîne de pions au centre il est venu
faire quelque chose d'un peu bizarre sur
l'ale donc le joueur blanc qui
finalement est allé gratter un pion à
cette pas forcément très utile mais qui
laisse la majorité centrale au noir qui
tôt ou tard un pur ont commencé à
pousser les pions de plus dans le france
dans la française on sait que c'est
souvent le flou de cases blanches qui
est le problème majeur des noirs est ici
le foie a été échangé un don il ya plus
du tout ce problème de fou donc les
noirs vont se développer tranquillement
mais ce passe pas encore tout à fait
fini c'est juste que l'ouverture ait
raté pour les blancs messages ou encore
fou fou des six qui a et b 5 bien joué
ça lui permet de remettre son cavalier
en jeu et de gagner un tempo sur le fou
maintenant fawcett aurait fallu faire
fouet cette direct ou pas pour pas
perdre pour pas perdre de temps disons
que si on joue food et 6 c'est plus sûr
cavaliers et cavaliers les cinq pour
revenir en baie vitrée bon sens ferme un
peu la tour après avoir mais je voulais
fouet cette aprés c'est une petite perte
de temps mon lait noir est bien mais les
blancs vont essayer de s'organiser
peut-être avec du food etc a toujours un
pour venir contrôler cette case 2,5 et
bloquer les pions si possible même si ça
va être dur donc la carre le cas bien
joué l'impression il vient prendre
il vient centraliser le cavalier
prépare-t-elle du fou et 6 pour taper
sur le pion c3 il faut peut-être quand
même faire food et 4 pour venir un peu
installé des pièces devant
c'est chose faite five 6 quand même
peut-être un peu tambour ou peut-être
essayé de temporiser avec les blancs
c'est pas facile commente addoustour
heures pour le moment par mesure de
développer une pièce budam b3 mais c'est
difficile de trouver de l'harmonie pour
les blancs ou peut-être prise prises et
d'amd 4 pour mettre la dame au centre
bruit joue h3c pas mauvais comme coup je
pense il temporise mais tour ses huit
classes à col saab sas à tour sur une
colline semi ouverte
c'est vraiment problématique d'art perdu
le centre adam t3 why not eu envie de
dire mais c'est compliqué hein dans le
sens où et noir vont s'installer donc
validé silva but visé maintenant la
casse c4
peut-être les blancs peuvent tenter
cavalier e 5 ou peut-être tenté tout re
1 et tout reprendre 4 donner une qualité
mais centraliser la dame ait regagné le
centre peut-être à terme je pense qu'il
faut prononcer 4 ça va permettre
d'échanger du matériel et mètres la tour
en oeuvre du f3 ça passe peut-être mais
ça me sas à la tête de quelque chose
d'assez dangereux
et prend 1,5
ça fait énormément de trous dans la
position blanche mais bon il réussit à
ramener un un cavalier au centre mais il
ya un pion au centre mais a
malheureusement qui à l'écran des trois
mais ça semblait pas du tout aller là
j'imagine sur calais france et 4 et les
peurs de tout reprend qu'ils attaquaient
un peu le fou avec ce pion c3 qui était
en prise aux 6 la position était
toujours difficile de toute façon je
sais pas s'ils pouvaient faire grand
chose à jouer tour un peu plus
rapidement
7 / fou des cats et de faire tout
repeint pour essayer de vous prendre des
quatre dames d'amis si j'aurais
peut-être plutôt jouer comme ça
personnellement mais là bon il a une
pièce d'une dame de moi je pense que
c'en est fini hhbc des qui est toujours
en course on va jeter un coup d'oeil
alors à chasse les idées qu'ils allaient
blanc donc cette partie là s'est passé
ce que nous pensions
[Musique]
on peut aller voir
alors allez voir au rêve voir notre note
notre collègue russe contre groucha
alors qu'est ce qui se passe à gauche à
la qui est quand même complètement
gagnant complètement gagnant il à tour
de plus et c'est fini qu'est-ce qu'on a
d'autres
on atterrit à 80 contre franck mais
franck il a plus de temps à la pendule
et là une pièce de moins il avait une
petite menace de maths en g2 mais ça va
pas passer francky va tomber
francky est tombé
regardez matin fr qui vous contre le
joueur le plus faible du tournoi 569
lots et ça devrait le faire pour mater
faire puisqu'il a une dame de plus en
plus grand chose
david roussel alors on n'a pas regardé
david roussel une petite finale et ça va
se jouer à la pendule alors la finale
il ya le pion pas ch pour les noirs mais
j'imagine que les blancs peuvent aller
le chercher ce pion 5 pas mal joué
l'aude va faire h4 l'imaginent roi fkng
cinq échecs 3 et 4 mai après les blancs
ou avec g6 mais pourquoi pas peut-être
mieux puisque sur gesse un café et f4
après
mais blanc beaucoup de pions passé je
pas trop mais le coup c 4 j'aurais
plutôt joué ses trois avec b 4 après
parce que là le danger c'est que le pion
se fasse se fasse attraper mais
heureusement pour david son adversaire
n'a plus de temps donc là dans cette
situation là quand on est comme ça
j'imagine qu'il vaut mieux jouer avec
ses 3 b 4 pour essayer d'avoir deux
pions passées est liée plutôt que de
jouer ces 4es de se retrouver avec un
seul ça peut servir d'en avoir deux qui
sont lisses entre protège et donc cette
partie là il reste plus que quelques
secondes aux blancs amri player qui va
perdre
il va se ferme à tanger de au prochain
il tente un dernier coup de bluff et
après d'apprendre d'eux de tant pis à
ils feront avec le fou mais bon ça
changera ses prix avec la dame ça gagner
juste plus vite mais ils gagnent autant
donc cette première ronde est terminée
on va directement les vers la deuxième
ronde et on va peut-être suivre le
leader du tournoi
le leader le favori je veux dire à rio
donc avec les noirs contre tant pis 2002
tant pis 2002 probablement née en 2002
je ne sais pas
alors
variante des changes de la slave tant
pis qui al'ambition peut-être sais pas
si c'est son répertoire principal mais
qui a peut-être l'ambition de de tenir
là nul envoie une période d'échangé la
slave
alors que se passe-t-il pour le moment
pas grand chose
mario qui se développe tranquillement
ils font un 8 qui contrôlent ya les fous
qui contrôle un peu la la la la dame jeu
mais qui va ramener le cavalier situe à
ramener le cavalier versé 4 directement
je sorte d'enclavé six cavaliers c4 ou
assise b5 et b6 key c4 après peut-être
possible aussi sur le bessin il faut
peut-être ce qui se passe après 1,4 mais
je pense qu'il a bep cap pour le moment
et puis à 5 et puis le cavalier qui
arrivera c'est ce qui fait attention
tout de même à ne pas se retrouver avec
sept tours et fuites qui pourraient
parvenir rejoindre l'action pour
contrôler la colonne s'est donc ça il
faut il faut s'en méfier
un cas j'imagine bekkat à 5 b45 efforts
c'est pas sûr peut-être faire cavalier b
6e si par exemple on ne puis un 4 mai à
cinq bons logique
la question à se poser c'est ce que les
blancs peuvent en profiter je veux
demander si on pouvait en profiter vous
faire pour penser huit dames français 8
et tour c'est pour essayer de gagner la
colonne c'est ça aurait pu être une
option
il a décidé de faire flamber 5 est allé
à échanger le fond 1,8 j'ai pas trop
aimé cet enchaînement de coups pas que
je n'aurais pas fait tout refoulé 5 dans
un deuxième temps mais juge j'aime pas
trop qui soit venu lui-même et changer
tout ça jusqu'à maintenant les normes
vont pouvoir faire du dam 17 ici damas
six aussi bien les deux possibles et
s'en prendre aux pions au point 4 il
veut aussi que cette femme décède pour
venir s'en prendre directement mais ça
va être un problème à l'est il se
contente du tour ces six dames c'est 2
du tour ces six pardon dams et deux sur
tours ces huit n'en fout g3 il évite les
mâles du couloir mais bon il perd un peu
de temps et il se fait dépasser sur sur
la colonne c'est je pense cependant
qu'avec le plan dont je parlais il y
aurait eu du cavalier c4 qui arrive et
là il ya quelque chose qui va pas pour
les blancs c'est trop passifs à ce que
les noirs vont perdre un temps effet
rachid pour éviter tous les problèmes du
clae blanc n'ont pas trop d'idées
apparemment possible pour éviter les
problèmes sur la huitième ranger
qui peut être une idée peut aussi venir
s'installer sur la casse ces quatre avec
la tour où le cavalier est la tour donc
là j'imagine que surtout reprend il veut
faire dame prend comme ça sur dame prend
il fera peut-être pions prend il y aura
le pion à 4 en ligne de fond attention
tout de même aux variantes un petit peu
comme ça a pris deux prises prise prise
fous ces sept cavaliers prend fou prend
à 5 et le fou qui va revenir attaqué la
case le pion b4 faut calculer toutes ces
choses là mais on trouve ces quatre très
fort un empire surtout content même joué
avec qui on prend et puis venir faire un
chip chaque avec la dame pour aller s'en
prendre aux pions au pion à ça à 4 dans
un deuxième temps aussi possible et
pousser cette mare en marquant comme
vous ils profitent surtout repenser
cette île à tour français 7 et il vient
mettre un peu le pion à 5 dans le viseur
et peut-être il veut se débarrasser du
cavalier position assez fermé c'est le
mauvais fout pas idiot ce coût de 2,2
tant pis
2002 mais j'aime bien dire le les
nombres bon
il ya plusieurs choses à faire pour les
noirs ici veut pas laisser le cavalier
dont cavaliers à 8 il va chasser le fou
il reviendra dans un deuxième temps donc
je pouvais à devoir repartir il va
peut-être mettre la dame en c6 comme ça
il menacera la tour c'est un ilat
contrôlera la casse ces sept et il
reviendra avec lecavalier en b 6 pour
attaquer le pion à 4 ça paraît tout à
fait possible dams et sisman emprise
prises et cavani b6 voilà c'est
exactement ce qu'il est en train de
faire bien joué de la part de mario
alors qu'on lui dit dans le choc la
cabine tactique on aa que que tout le
monde a raté tout reprend ses sept tours
france et 7 est fou des six échecs
bien vu le chat bien vu le chat est le
joli tactique gagné arriola raté aussi
là il faut regarder les choses plus
stratégique mais ça gagne quand même il
va jouer dame prend à cède 1.4 et ça va
y aller c'est facile à gagner quand même
il va aller tôt ou tard prendre le pion
prendre le pion à 4,2 déjà peut-être
même le prendre avec avec la dame en
fait je pense qu'il peut déjà jouer aux
dames prend 1,4 moi ce que je le rate
quelque chose je vois pas vraiment où
est le soucis est changée en avant avec
food et 6 je sais pas d'un point 4 me
paraissait un me paraissait bon aussi
d'un point 4 qui va arriver au prochain
cavalier points 4 même d'ailleurs
n'a pas nié vouloir s'embêter avec le
fou de cases noires je pense je pense
qu'il ya pas vu ce qu'il a il avoue une
passe en bétail des variantes comme ça
en fait
mais bon il aurait eu peut-être
cavaliers detroit quand même qui protège
bon je sais pas c'est qu'il y avait
autre chose que j'ai pas vu mais là ça
devrait aller il va pouvoir encaisser le
pion b are you et pousser le plus loin
jusqu'au bout ça devrait aller avec à 4
à 3 à 2 à 1 dames qui arrive
tempier qui trouve du contre je passe
qui menace d'un projet 5 et il a une
deuxième menace c'est dans ce but 8
échecs et dame prend v6c d'un v8 échec
et dames trembler 6
aïe aïe aïe le dame g3 qui revenait on
l'avait raté suit la lame qui revient
les cavaliers qui tombe et ça va pas
être si simple dames eu cinq échecs il
prend pas le cavalier parce qu'il y
avait le cavalier e 2 qui tombait mais
je pense que il y aurait pu tenter de
devenir maîtres d échec derrière car les
deux qui restent en prison mais bon j'ai
l'impression qu'on pouvait tenter suroît
g7 en fait j'ai pas eu le temps de dire
mais je pensais qu'on pouvait tenter sur
roy g7 d'apprendre deux têtes des cinq
ans fait avec l'idée amis avaient d'amd
un échec et dame prend des cinq ans
dommage dommage j'aurais même idée même
idée malheureusement ça marchait pas
peut-être qu'ils allaient tenter de
garder le cavalier alors peut-être qu'il
fallait tenter de garder le cavalier ici
peut-être par le mail qu'il fallait
tenter de peut-être d'amay fuite
cette faille tenté de la mef 8 après roy
h7 tiens à mes fit sa part et c'est pas
mal ça menacé dame prend f7 et le roi
pouvait pas monter tient dans ma fuite
je me demande si ça faisait pas nul
parce que le droit vous le roi devait
monter et apprécié le roi monte
ils devraient finir là il devait venir
ici elle avait peut-être d'amd 8 qui le
piège simon dia cavaliers j'ai trois
mois il aurait pu retourner du coup bon
à voir il faudrait pouvoir analyser plus
mais bon
gagner pour are you mais il a pu avoir
chaud au monde et ça ça pouvait être un
peu dangereux
miley 42 ans prise ça aurait pu être
dangereux
alors là je pense qu'il où la lie à plus
trop tant il ya plus trop de temps pour
les deux joueurs
markarian quidam bien échec la sonde
américaine bear échec est d'alger 6 très
bien vu peut-être peut-être sur d'un
méchoui 3g 6 aussi passé avec avec le
roi qui repartait de l'autre côté
possible aussi
c'est pas mais ne sait pas trop pourquoi
escariot peut nous écrire dans le chatt
pourquoi il s'est débarrassé d'eux
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a joués food et
six en fait
alors on est reparti
alors on va suivre pascal go contre
casse pas des briques
alors défense française éventuellement
dus qu'à valider deux cavaliers c3e 5
peut prendre des cinq les casse-cou
principaux pôles ici même joué food et 3
donc la varende davance c5 c3 donc pas
comme dans la partie précédente à qui on
vient vient protéger la case des quatre
d'or à rillieux qui met pas trop les
fossatois et mais juste pour répondre le
chat surtout c7 est la variante avec
d'un point 4 qui les prend à 4 et 10
pouces et sept cavaliers prend des deux
tables clip tout et revenir en d3 et ça
a l'air pas mal du tout pour protéger le
pion et éviter de te faire fixer sur
noir dans ce qu'on ait raté quelque
chose dans la variante mais séparés
c'est plus simple en tout cas à première
vue donc qui a fait ces trois dames b6
cavaliers eux deux qui ont créé en pions
prend qu'à verser 6 cavaliers c3 je suis
pas sûr je connais pas la théorie ici
mais c'est rare que je trouve en fait de
prendre trop tour en d4 qui permet en
fait aux blancs de reprendre et de
libérer la casse ces trois pour le
cavalier c'était être intéressant de
garder un peu la pression sur sur la
case des cas puisque maintenant le
cavalier blanc vient se balader alors
qu'elle va dire à 4 bon c'était pas si
grave que ça pour les noirs des quatre
échecs toujours dangereux puisqu'il ya
peut-être fou d2 et la dame
la dame d'avoir de moins en moins de gaz
puisqu'on peut pas prendre des quatre
cavaliers on peut pas prendre attaque la
dame on peut pas prendre b2 il ya le
cavalier hockey dimpre en d2 pour mais
ça c'est autant abandonner alors je sais
pas il aurait pu peut-être faire dame b
mais là dessus avait j'imagine cavaliers
f4 et la dame n'avait plus de gaza - ce
que je me trompe mais là toutes les
cases de la dame était contrôlé mais bon
dame b4 sa santé le coup dangereux jouer
rapidement moment va on va changer de
parti
alors à rien crouch à gros chat qui pour
le moment est à 2 sur 2 il fait un beau
tournoi contre héros datham donc un d
outsider un des outsideurs et donc on a
une position structure de pions de type
benoni avec les blancs qui ont essayé de
mener les deux mais la taxe sur le pion
des 6 mai nord ont bien défendu et à
présent
un peu tout qui s'échangent mai et noir
vont réussir à se réactive et là parce
que le cavalier peut pas rester ici
alors est ce que ça paraît risqué mais
ce qu'on peut l'amener vers ces six pour
essayer de se faire protéger par le pion
même une fois ans et si c'est ce qui
aurait vraiment été utile je sais pas
c'était quand même à envisager d'essayer
de moi je sais pas pour montrer juste
une idée pour essayer au cas où de
prendre avec le le pur ans et si c'est
quelque part active et le fouet f3 mais
qui protégera un pion bien placé donc ça
aurait pu être une idée est d'aller en
fait si on fait ça je sais pas si le
cavalier on sait si ces méga utile mais
bon il contrôle quand même 5 et il
paraît pas si mal placé que ça même si
parfois les cavaliers peuvent être sûr
des pieuvres qui peuvent être pas être
si forte
un hibou c4 j'aime pas trop ces quatre
ça vient prendre la case du cavalier et
ça permet aux fous de de briller sur la
diagonale mais bombay 3 bien joué il
enlève toutes les pièces de cette
diagonale il va peut-être essayé ensuite
de venir avec du damas deux mais il va
arriver en deuxième
malheureusement puisqu'il prenait 3
c'est quand même une menace fou prend
prise ça donnait pas des masses en vie
et maintenant je pense qu'il va apporter
quelque chose comme damas est qui va
arriver
macadam qui peut essayer de rentrer
après vers à 3h présent cavaliers à
saint calais cécité était envisageable
ok j'ai quatre bien joué ce que j'étais
en train plus ou moins de penser en
imaginant les blancs mené une attaque
avec du fourrage 6 ce truc réjouissant
pour les blancs c'est que le cavalier
pour le monde participe pas aux jeux le
cavalier ses limites
ok alors là il faut prendre son temps
avec les blancs et un petit peu
réfléchir donc l'idée dames 1 c'était
d'avoir protégé cinq cavaliers âge 6
échecs faisait pas sans ce qu'il prend
une fois nous on peut peut-être faire
nul dans la finale de pièces mineures
avec les blancs
mais mon truc c'est qu'il va garder les
dames sur l'échiquier je pensais avec
les noirs en tout cas au début il va
peut-être mettre la dame en c3 pas sûr
que le cahier puisse vraiment
s'approcher
le cavaly va venir vers f5
il faut l'empêcher de venir sur f5 km le
fou en d3 ça c'est sûr mais la dame va
arrive en c3 mais bon peut-être la
prendre c'est pas grave je viens il faut
mettre le fou en d3 quand même je pense
pas qu'il faille tolérer le cavalier qui
rentre à f/5 ce qu'a pris peut arriver
vers des 4 et s'approcher dangereusement
du pion b3 je pense vraiment qu'il faut
mettre ce fou en d3 et arrêté empêcher
aux cavaliers de rentrer et sur dame c3
est vraiment prendre
et puis après ramener le roi toute façon
le soutien et le cavalier a du mal à se
ramener ça doit pouvoir se tenir cette
histoire
désagréable mais ça doit pouvoir se
tenir
voilà
on aime des 4
trois dames ici peut-être fou g5
maintenant si les noirs font rien
peut-être fou g5 pour aller s'emparer du
du cavalier empêcher vente ul mans h4h 4
ça peut être pénible ce que ça peut
venir affaiblir le roi fou g5 c'est pas
mal piri frafu f6 on pourra toujours
faire quelque chose aux qualifs et
affiche 6 mai c'est un affaiblissement à
long terme quand même f6 maintenant
probablement fouet f4 on revient en
proposent les changes et on a quand même
obtenir un petit quelque chose le roi
devient de plus en plus faible pas quand
les noirs peuvent leur chance alors ils
doivent quand même et sylvain nombre
d'échangés les dames peut-être mettre
leur on arrive cet échange les dames
je me demande si les blancs peuvent
tenter prise prisé et de ramener la dame
en h6 ondam e3 plus sage
voilà c'est ce qui fait l'échangé
d'année mais je pense qu'il ya dame
prend des quatre on peut pas reprendre
du fou on doit reprendre du pillon et
fous des deux camps surtout prend il ya
fou prend des six est sûre pions prend
et afu d2 et on vient sans prendre
option b 4 et là on est mieux avec les
blancs ces voix là puis on promet
maintenant fou des deux c'est le coût
important avoir en fait ici le coût des
deux importants et on s'en prend pions
b4 et et les noirs se sont auto
magouiller mais vont gagner autant voilà
prise prises et maintenant le roi va
venir en g2 ramener le roi au centre
gauche à qui va tout bien faire mais qui
va perdre autant pour f3 et puis après
envoyé les mobylettes les gros bill est
allé droit en f3 active et petit à petit
cette fois à saint cloud et 8 ici
rapidement elle joue bien et je veux
bien gros chat fo qui peut revenir vers
des huit dommage parce qu'ici après fou
des limites échec le roi devait reculer
on pouvait encore gagner un pion mémoire
des cinq là c'est fini
cavalli ces cinq façons il ya plus de
temps et en plus ce qu'elle va être
forte en cavalier ici il attend mais bon
de toute façon il ya plus de temps
franges et 6 pour marcher et 5 et vous
projet social mais juste je veux dire
par là qu'on arrive on réussira pas à
pousser les pions avec les pions lit et
peut-être qu'on a réussi à avancer mais
l'on pouvait pas dommage pour pour héros
datham est réfugié cisr direct 3e set
juste quelqu'un que j'ai pas trop aimé
ça donnait des cases dommage il aurait
mérité de la gagne elle on va voir gary
francis contre eux ahmed pas qu'on les
ait vu c'est un massacre année blythe et
ce n'est pas un massacre il n'y a plus
de temps pour les blu ray c'est ça être
marrant de secondes 9 deux tours de plus
il
faire faire tout en promouvant peut-être
mettre le fou ans et 6 7e rang à 7
la tour ici et le fou qui vient en c4 ce
serait pas mal à ypres et mauvais tout
ça ça pourrait faire un math même de
près mauvais tour ses 7es à 4 c 7 à 4
encore plus fort il va pas trouver asile
à tour à quatre ans près vous aussi mais
il y aura roi c3 vrai dommage dommage
que s'ils avaient pré move et s'ils
avaient pré move est ici pour ses sets
le roi n'a plus de gaz puis on prend et
à quatre matchs dommage dommage
allez on va les voir un choc the
alligator donc il ya déjà gagné le
tournoi contrario un choc au sommet
madras qui a battu groucha les gros
chars et qui méritaient la victoire
c'était c'est bien joué de la part de
gruchet à gauche à aller sicilienne pour
pour are you qui a six rondes en
tournant en ami tournoi
à
alors
une seconde où en sommes nous une
sicilienne donc les blancs ont joué lars
ohly mots les persos dans cette variante
la haye je jouais la vente avec d'amd 6
ie6 bon je connais pas trop ça jouait
pas trop trop à mon époque ça donc et
qui est venu en c3 j'aime bien jouer que
ces trois des quatre mais on doit les
gars tort qu'ils jouent dans l'esprit à
fond il envoie les pions h
mais le pion hk je suis pas convaincu
puisque toutes façons de cavalier noir
va venir vers eux 5
ça me paraît un peu too much nageurs
flo7 car il ya eu cinq sets carrés lieu
cinq maintenant
prise est prise et c'est quelque chose
comme dams et 6 après et b6 fou bessette
ou dams et 6 des cinq jeunes abc stamm
c6 v6 ou b cette attention quand même
sur dame sait si c'est un piège et f4
marrant et lecavalier a plus de cases
marans a déjà fait dames c'est celle qui
est pas tombé dans le panneau il va
remettre le cavalier sur ses six frères
ça aurait été un piège assez drôle ça
aurait été un piège assez marrant et il
va il va pouvoir développer le fou en
fuyant kétou et j'ai peur pour le roi
blanc quand même parce que jouer avec f4
ça fait vraiment peur est en fait ils
ont fait genre des 3b six f4 je pense
les noirs veulent juste faire cavalier
f3 dame prend un f4 peut-être que les
blancs doit jouer avec des quatre ici
comme dans une sicilienne ouverte pour
essayer de tirer profit de du manque de
développement des noirs dont il fait à 5
pas mal aussi avec l'idée d'empêcher abc
soit et c'est assez logique à 5
c'est assez bien joué ok j'ai 5
si chacun a envie de faire des cats que
j'allais dire d'autant plus envie marc
le fur et angers 5 prises est prise pour
s'en prendre un peu cavalier aux
cavaliers 5 avec la tour à tour pas
forcément bien placé parce que là est
papa de carélie c6 maintenant est ce
qu'à ce v6 assez bien
pour le cas et donc j'ai mis sur pied à
la cat se faire caillasser système qui à
fait fou 3
de même venir échanges dans mes changé
d'âme je pense pas mais en fait marrant
à ce qu'il a fait avec à quatre avec hk
page 5 intéressant les noirs qui envoie
font maintenant il va peut-être faire
cavalier f3 échec
tiens je pense qu'il va faire cavalier
je pense qu'il peut faire cavalier f3
échec sur fou prend il pourra faire dame
prend pays 6 éventuellement et reprendre
mais bon est-ce que c'est vraiment grave
il faut calculer peut circuler la dame
éventuellement faire bêtement d'un bep 8
finalement cette dame en b si ce n'est
peut-être pas si dangereuse et garder
ses menaces vers le roi marrant son
plein et que j'ai 500 g 8 g 4 à
s'amusant à fond dans l'esprit l'esprit
de la grob
alors les blancs qu'est ce qui doit
faire ici c'est toujours ce cas relief 3
qui traînent des 3 h un prophylactique
mais bon il y enfermer le roi là bas
dans le coin c'est pas forcément notre
côté il ya des pièces noires qui
participa à la teinte donc ça doit pas
afin c'est quand même dangereux mais
normand ça doit pas passer
il ya dans mon n'y a pas assez de pièces
en jeu pour les noirs donc normalement
quelque chose comme roy h-13 h un pardon
ça doit être possible parce qu'en fait
je pensais aussi à tour d un mais là
j'ai peur qu'on se fasse ça ça me fait
un peu peur sa menace damas chamade déjà
et ça c'est un peu chiant
la fille roi h 1
mon père disait qu du fou j'ai 5 pour
réussir à faire rejoindre la tour
position position étrange au quai cale
et c6 pas idiot non plus hein il veut
venir faire cavalli dames 5 et dame
prend h55 les pièces blanches ne
réussissent pas une tour d'un il ramène
la d'amoureux 5 très bien joué
maintenant une pions madame par yvan h5
le cavalier va venir ont eu 5 il va y
avoir des menaces après une fois que les
dames sera chaque cas est enceinte
convard menacé cavaliers f3 d'autant
plus fortement et bizarrement même si
les noirs sont pas développés les pièces
blanches savent pas à grand chose
il fait d'un match 5 et à faire cavalier
e 5 et il menace cavaliers f3 maintenant
ça va pas être évident
qui peut très bien se faire mater là il
peut très bien se faire mater de manière
même quasi forcée puisque sa masse comme
cavalier f3 prise prisé sur g3 damas
trois déjà et les pièces blanches
servent à rien étrangers ils vont
pousser les pions de partout et puis
finalement ils sont fait contrer manière
assez marrante ils tendent qu'à valider
cinq
j'imagine qu'il ya énormément de choix
et peut-être même jusqu'à vallier f3 en
fait pour aller simplement mater en
force
ne s'occupant pas des menaces blanche
sorte cavaliers f3 de toute façon pris
ce prise et on a toutes les menaces à
mais peut-être faire cavalier 4 pour
rejoindre la défense ils n'ont pas
cavalier 6 est un qui ne servira à rien
ici et sur puis on prend il veut jouer
tout reprend et comme ça sur cavaliers
f3 y aura y aura enfin de mariage la
menace sur la dame dont cavaliers dessin
qui réussit à un petit peu défendre donc
puis on prend des cinq tours prend des
singles ça ça va être jouée à tempo et
maintenant les noirs ont quand même à
mon avis énormément de coups il joue
tour g6 peut-être dames c'est cette
tempo et prend du temps où là il prend
trop de temps et à la dame qui tombe
donc voilà c'est possible d'abandonner
injuste tout réussissait tout
réussissait à la dame qui traînait mais
juste prise prises et tous réussissent
par exemple et c'est fini nous reprend
1,6 ou n'importe quoi mais il aurait pu
le faire d'un match 4 c'était vraiment
fini cette histoire mais en fait ici
dams et 7 peut-être mais y aurait ce que
bon il est pas tout si sa cause de fou
prend et il voulait faire dame prend ici
peut-être ramener la tour en d1 et jouer
tout reprend 17
je suis quasi sûr qu'il ya des choses
qui marchent un pur pour les noirs mais
bon quand même pu essayer de survivre un
petit peu
peut-être même juste des six qui bloque
la connexion et tout est protégé
il faut aussi sa pré qui arrivés petit à
petit les pièces lors se développe mais
bon les noirs ont gagné donc c'est gagné
et il reste hhbc des qui a gagné qui a
gagné une position perdante qui a gagné
autant alors on est reparti
je suis trompé sur quelqu'un qui avait
gagné peut-être qu'ils avaient gagné
autant tout à l'heure et c'est tombé
alors est ce qu'on continue à suivre les
leaders who is conçu un peu en dessous
qu'est ce qui a bien pu regarder le
classement
il ya maintes affaire qui est pas mal
classés lorsque ça donne contre pascal
bour joueurs suisses
alors voulez un point sur le classement
faire un point classement alors on a
deux joueurs encore à tête
are you et roda tam et ensuite on espèce
de groupe etc taille alligator matt
réfère donc on est en train de suivre
qui fait un bon tournoi
save the beast chez dress mexicain
garrigues francis aussi fait un bon
tournoi
a fortiori pascal go et après on a un
joueur qui est déjà qui a déjà fait cinq
parties donc il ya deux sur cinq car on
a tout un tas de joueurs à 2 puis 1
et puis les joueurs qui sont qui sont
sortis du tournant
alors qu'est ce qu'on a ici comme
position pour le moment ça vient de quoi
cette histoire c'est devenu une bouée
indienne viennent alors est ce que les
blancs vont réussir à utiliser leurs
centres ou pas
afin que ces trois est ce qu'on va
réussir à jouer quatre peut-être un jour
ou pas souvent c'est l'idée 1 dans les
ouvertures avec des quatre c'est de
revenir et de réussir à jouer
le 4s qui a joué par exemple ou des
trois ici il veut il veut menacer 4 mai
les noirs vont peut-être faire des
saints car pas forcément tout de suite
à
l'a5 et sur quatre est ce qu'ils vont
jouer le dessin qui a attaqué la tour
mais ce que ça c'est un problème
clément fouquerel bessin qui profite du
coup à cinq pour placer le cavalier sur
cette caste faible parce qu'ils n'en
peuvent faire genre fou c'est cissé s'en
débarrasser parce que ça s'appelle
depuis les genres fous ces six vous
prend prise m le pur en d5 et latour ans
et 8 ans qu'il joue avec eux cinq et il
profite du fait que les blancs puisse
pas faire des 5 à cause de quatre
notamment mais peut-être pas que donc
ils gardent le fouet s'est pas passé
loin d'être idiot à ce qu'il est en
train de faire mais là sur des 5 il y
avait 4 c'était pas mal joué ce coût de
c'était pas un jouet du tout
je pense et ce qu'ils voulaient faire
sur quatre d'ailleurs ces blancs jouent
eux quatre j'ai pensé à des singes
savants avec des tactiques
enfin il y avait des 5 avec cette
tactique là avec cette espèce de double
attaque
mais il faut aussi souligner qu'ils
pouvaient aussi avoir désisté avait que
5 et sur cavaliers des cinq sets c'est
pas si grave tête il pouvait prendre
éventuellement va pas forcément mais je
reprendre prendre prendre prendre et
récupérer la casse ces 5
quoique là quand même ça faisait un peu
un peu peur mais bon en tout cas là sur
4 jusque là il avait des cinq qui
permettait de faire la double attaque et
après carélie b 5e 5 c'était très bien
joué cinq des cinq issifou c2 et
cavaliers c5
qu'est ce que je vois pas surpris en pro
f 3 en fait dit mais des mois dans le
chat et des mois dans le tchad je sois
il ya quelque chose que je zappe
complètement parce qu'il a joué après
j'ai rien compris je comprends juste pas
quel problème impression avec trois
sauts c'est moi qui hallucine
sans oublier de revenir la thur excusez
moi qui est complètement dingue
non mais il peut rien à voir c'est pas
possible bon rassurez moi dans le tchat
rassurez moi dans le chat que je sais
pas c'est quelqu'un peut peut me sauver
j'ai vraiment pas compris ce qui se
passait là la position du coût est de
nouveau complètement dingue mais les
blancs c'est pas mal pour eux parce
qu'ils en récupèrent la case f5 et
peut-être peut-être le pion des six qui
peut être tapé un moment donné dont 44
bien placé il protège ça il va casser si
ceci pour le monde foulhac ouvre
peut-être faire c'est de faire revenir
cette tour en jeu avec les blancs dans
un premier temps je pas si partout rade
et on essaye de passer par là ou pas
retour à troyes où partout ras et puis
la tour revient mais enfin je pense
qu'il faut faire participer cette tour
au jeu dommage d'investrust pas possible
à cause de cavalli d2 pour le moment
mais mon tête tour à 1 il faut faire
participer cette tour bon personne n'a
rien vu vous me rassurez surplus en coin
3 gt angers tempérer ce cavalier ça que
j'aurais quand même ramené la tour en
justesse peut-être pas un mauvais coup
en attention mais je déteste avoir des
pièces hors jeu comme ça il fait
frisquet programme la la à oui mais
qu'elle prendrait si ce temps il ya eu
main il ya le magnétar premier fils mais
du coup il a calé prend b5 et oui et
c'est pas forcément bon échange si stora
là parce que les noirs ils vont
commencer à s'activer de partout où je
suis pas s'ils prennent en bessin
courant des cinq après il a commencé à
voir de la menace de partout et de
toutes façons c'est pas une bonne
opération et le fait qu'ils
réfléchissent à paris qu'elle prendrait
si ça prouve bien que matt affaire
n'avait pas vu donc il a un peu de champ
de leur tour preuve 6 mais maintenant ça
prend là il va prendre
et là il ya plein de trucs emprise il
fait dams est à double attaque bien vu
mais il ya demain mais c'est quand même
très fort ce que dame arrive alors dame
prendre trois échecs on va devoir faire
peut-être trois ici la tour prends mais
si ce qu'est ce qui se passe
il ya juste d'apprendre trois échecs ici
et là me prendre les six dames e set
c'était bien vu c'était joli et comme
quoi cette tour à trois qui étaient mal
placés depuis tout à l'heure je vous
disais que j'avais envie de la ramener
et évidemment la main comme il faut
quand même défendre quelque chose quoi
mais bon la position était difficile
un tour de moins c'est fini alors on va
essayer de voir est ce que ça joue
encore ta ble allez on va filer vers la
table e1 avec cariou qui normalement on
va pas pouvoir gagner ça ah mais il peut
jouer la pendule escariot va être classé
laisser la nuit où est ce que mario va
être pas classe et faire tomber son
adversaire
telle est la question est ce qu'on est
classe on est ce qu'on n'est pas classe
vous savez que moi je ne serai pas
classe c'est un tournoi j'essaierai de
la gagner mais bon on va pas forcément
influencé à rio à faire des choses qui
pourraient regretter plus tard peut-être
que ces élèves le regarde pas forcément
un bon exemple mais bon j'aurais tenté
de faire tomber
je pense qu'il va le faire hein
je pense qu'il va le faire
lire data métaphore de bull a été oui
mais bon quand même un gros retard à la
pendule prêt peut peut-être la tenir
ça va être intéressant de voir est ce
qui va tomber ou pas va-t-il tomber ou
va-t-il ne pas tomber en fait that is
the question
mais alors il a passé la tour derrière
compliqué
qu'est-ce qu'il va réussir à amener le
roi vert peut-être qu'ils passent par
ces 6 mai y arrive quoi que fasse froid
c'est si c'est qu'il espère tour c1 mais
bon roi 17
il y aura quand même même au pire tout
re 1 voilà il temps de ça mais
maintenant il a un pion de - soissons
c'est ingagnable sans jouer la pendule
mais bon il prend des risques parce que
maintenant l'eau tivaoune tour d2 c'est
dommage il aurait pu être remonté droit
direct le roi était bien couper là on
aurait peut-être plus envie de de filer
vers le pion g4 pour jouer la gagne mais
il va la jouer solide mais parfois c'est
mieux de de jouer les attaques après
pour essayer carrément de la gagner et
mettre l'adversaire en difficulté qui
doit arriver et changer les pièces ça il
va être obligé de je vois pas comment il
peut peut tout près move après
mais bon il va sûrement prémont un coup
de tours sur la colonne à j'aurais bien
je retour ici si j'étais à rio à
rillieux qui propose nul
are you qui est classe quand même hein
et il reste deux alligators ça c'est
complètement fini années veut pas qui
comble alligator tension le pion à six
semaines on peut aller parce partir de
l'autre côté si on aller choper le pur
adverse
histoire d'être sûr de pas bon il va
passer ses pions mais il peut aussi un
peu s'y faire bras b6 et puis filet de
l'autre côté en promouvant tout
bon et si de gagner comme ça ça gagne
aussi 1 ces histoires de près move est
d'être sûr de ne pas tomber et surtout
de gagner une pure ashes pour ne pas
perdre et donc il reste une partie la
dernière ronde donc à rillieux et roda
tam tous les deux à quatre et demi et
derrière on est à 4
ça veut dire que ça va jouer ça peut se
jouer au départage héros d'atteindre un
meilleur des partages donc ça peut se
jouer à pas grand-chose ce tournoi je
propose qu'on suive aller le maître
international quand même alors ça joue
une petite cg pagny talent et ça joue à
un espèce de d'ouverture avec le
cavalier l'heureux le cavaliere 3
retardés suis pas comment ça s'appelle
ça les change pas mal auquel adam
parvenir en des 8es les plus en vue avec
ses trois des qatari là il a donné
rapidement le fou de deux cases noires
une position assez égal je pense à la
sortie d'ouverture tue pas convaincu du
coup cavaliers de 3 mais bon pourquoi
pas puis je me sens que les gens vont
essayer de faire ces six des cinq
maintenant mais bon pourquoi pas ce
cavalier trois remarques intéressantes
imagina 5
voici ce ou ces six d'ailleurs est fait
tous les coups étaient possibles
désirent mieux jouer je pense que sur
hassen qui veut faire prise et le fou
peut être un peu 100 cases en fait
servette pas mal cette histoire pour les
noirs commenté blanc et quelques choses
sympas mal j'ai pas dire qu'ils sont
forcément beaucoup mieux mais ça a l'air
de pas mal se tenir on va dire ça comme
ça
ici pour les noirs parce que là il ya
beaucoup de cafu prend 1,3 et dessins
qui est forcément candidat mais bon il
est peut-être le plus simple qu'un peu
faible après je pensais même à roye h7
mais je crois pas que ça marche avec
l'idée surprise de faire des cinq pour
enfermer le fou et je pense que le
minimum flash 5 est bon il faudra encore
calculé tout ça et six cavaliers pour le
ceinturer passant blitz en tout cas donc
la fesfut prend prise prise prise il va
tout prendre four b3 et où il aura le
temps de faire re 4 en fait à la femme
prétend qu'il a il ay la raison de jouer
comme ça ou d'amd s'ils souhaitent fait
ça ça libère pas mal de pièces les plans
peut-être enterré à jaillir à jouer des
4 ou 4
rapidement peut-être on a développé les
pièces où est donc b6 il peut peut-être
jouer du fouet si c'est un moment donné
ou fauve et savent d'ailleurs pourquoi
pas et avec les blanches jouerait des
cats que j'allais dire parce qu'on a
plus le fou de cases noires donc on veut
mettre les pions sur cases noires c'est
assez logique et on menace le pion aux
cinq en plus donc les noirs vont pousser
et on peut jouer cavalier d2 par exemple
cavalier e 5 4 a lieu cinq faire gaffe à
f6 sur m6 ou valve cavaliers d'ailleurs
on voit le cavalier sur f6 ça peut la
question qu'on est en droit de se poser
ici qui va nulle part ce cavalier
ayvaz verges et six avec la tactique où
la cdu est ratée par are you ça aussi
sympa comme tactique prise et il va
faire [ __ ] en d5 échec joli joli mais
bon il y avait les varois issifou prend
à 8 es fou aussi ce jeu et cetera teaser
est sûre fou aussi sur la tête des cinq
encore parfois si ceux ci
donc faut aussi ce des cinq forcé pour
essayer de tenir un peu quelque chose
eh bien non même fou j'ai quatre
cavaliers 5 févr et toutes les pièces
blanches qui sont bleues kallel allèles
dame est maintenant tête du f 5 tours et
fisc et cinq tours j'ai si cela toute la
bonne compagnie là ça va arriver de
partout la life 5-6 tour j 6 alors les
blancs corps ils doivent défendre damas
trois bien joué et baa3 sa force l
échange de dames à cause de la tour
eiffel qui était en prison clé blanc
joue bien mieux que les noirs en fait je
vois assez bien et grands dans cette
partie il trouve des ressources de
partout
damas 3 était assez joli fallait mais
les blancs tactiquement on était quand
même assez affûté avec le quart eli g6
le machin le truc là fut envoyé pas mal
de tactique de partout alors avec les
noirs faut qu'on récupère du matos
bonfoh de bien jouer va mettre dix va
aller il va les mettre le fou vers
détroit
le cavalier qui va devoir partir il
réussit pas récupéré de matos c'est en
russe ouais c'est quand même la cata
pour les noirs c'est quand même la cata
skalli t pions moins ça va être
difficile
donc avait lieu 5 avoir faire du tour
ces huit c'est de récupérer au moins un
pion pour tenir là nul après mais
peut-être fou difficile de savoir
comment les noirs peur tu allais jouer
le tout pour le tout mais récupère un
pion mais je pense que cette finale là
je transforme assez bien avec les tours
qui vont doubler sur à puis la tour qui
va venir en a 7 pour jouer sur la 7e il
faut qu'il fasse froid 6 et g5 peut-être
se faire mater avec du g4 qui va arriver
banquet f5 tour à sept tours g6 donc
tour à 6 soit bien jouer est là le
problème c'est que c'est que tout
reprend b6 et tour c'est ce à quoi se
prend du tour b 5 pour prendre tout
reprend ici mais ces erreurs là
peut-être touré fils qui ai pas tout
réussi c'est peut-être encore peut-être
encore prise en b3 mais peut-être
peut-être tours fc est derrière
ils ont l'embarras du choix de toute
façon
mais moi réussissent quand même à
s'activer un peu
je pense car aucune menace objective
mais bon peut faire peur
le truc je pense c'est que les blancs
sont en train de regarder ci peut
arriver quelque chose comme ça genre
faire un échec à chez le roi ici et
avoir l'autre j'ai pas qui peut-être f4
surprise ici poussé pions mètres la tour
en d2 tête avec la tour en d2 avant ils
font trois
il peut y avoir des idées br / c'est
simple et les noirs ont joué avec 4
direct mais j'aurais peut-être mis un
échec avant de faire f4 pas que de toute
façon
soissons s'est perdue tour d un évêque
le roi en même en hd
bref deux danses marche aussi tour d2
les rois de trois mois j'ai trois tours
détroit airwatch de maintenant
le problème c'est que c'est ce qu'on
voyait sur trois y aura toujours tours
tours 8 août ont réussi ce qui stoppera
tout ça
d un temps encore et puisque tout art la
tour était en d1 faire la tour est en d1
ce qui change et là maintenant il ya
food et 1 mais bon même food est en fait
sa menace rien on peut juste faire c6 c7
en fait il fait eu deux baroque et ses 6
2 il se casse un peu la tête ce qui
rentre dans une finale deux tours mais a
les gagnants faire la tour qui arrive
derrière le pion est donc maintenant on
va pouvoir monter le roi et ses gagnants
c'est un petit coup de tours c'est 5
pour visser mais bon même pas la peine
ce que sur wife 5 il ya la tour qui
vient est maintenant 4 et ça va le faire
mais peut-être la tour ans et cinq
femmes ont ils avaient même sacrifié la
qualité pour rien et il est mal autant
sept de ces aides il a sacrifié la
qualité pour y en a eu deux et il n'a
pas fait cinq ans plus bas à l'info fait
retour g5 rapidement heureusement qu'il
a vu tout rejet 5 es le roi qui passent
du bon côté escariot va réussir à le
faire tomber tours à 6 ou tour quelque
part c'est difficile quand même de faire
tomber et 7z qui se fait peur 7 de celle
qui se fait peur
plus tour c'est simple suis pas sûr que
ce soit bien joué en terme de temps ce
qui va un peu mais il fallait faire
tomber cinq essais 7 il m'a l'air de
ramer en recettes qui va revenir
elle a fait j'ai cinq ans qu'ils
allaient faire recette plus tôt quand
même réussir à faire une dame et ça doit
le faire pour cette z
attendez attendez
ok il m'a fait peur et j'ai peur qu'ils
voient pas le match avec moi j'ai vu un
match en trois voyages avait vu le pré
move un peu bête damev cinq tours ici
est damée fuite maths et donc vous allez
gator qui gagne une nouvelle fois le
tournoi devant celle de seb et are you
finalement donc il n'ya pas qui n'a pas
réussi à remporter le tournoi heroes
date and donc c'est marrant à les deux
joueurs académies ont tous les deux
perdu contre ceux qui avaient 4 et
finalement ils se font ils se font
doubler
ils se font doubler et on finit on finit
avec avec donc ce trio et les outsider
qui ont réussi à taper le scalp du
maître international je disais ça en
sera très difficile à gagner
après mon milieu de tableau il va les
habitués et tout un tas d'autres joueurs
j'espère que vous êtes bien amusé en
jouant ce tournoi vous êtes bien marrer
eh ben je vous dis à jeudi prochain et
le prochain tournoi mensuel bitstream ce
sera donc jeudi jeudi jeudi jeudi 5
septembre mais normalement il y aura le
match de carl scène quand elle sera le
vendredi 6 en attendant je vous dis à
tout le monde
à très bientôt ciao